hello hello
hello hello hello all right
hello there
mr jeff perfect way to enter hello there
super pumped hey what's up javi what's
going on dude
how you been man
what's up forsaken what's going on
everybody hello there hello there that's
gotta be the thing when we do the kenobi
streams it has to be hello there
hello there oh thanks hunter
yo jaby in the chat
we ready for episode i guys i i
i am so excited
i'm so excited about episode three like
this series the first two episodes like
oof they fire
they so good
oh
hello there yes hello there's in the
chat
so at star wars celebration
uh
the opening ceremony um
you know like as it's like they have
like a dj and stuff like before it
starts right and like a like like a host
who just like you know
gets everybody hype and stuff like that
but when it starts you know like let's
go down blah blah blah everything plays
and then ill mcgregor and hayden
christensen are the first people to walk
on the stage and then
and then anyone just takes the mic and
just goes hello there and we all just
like
we all freaked out
uh tkd man 2011. thank you i love you
too
thank you thank you thank you for the
super chat hello there hello there i
love it i love it um
uh
oh yeah i am like
i guess i am super early for the chat
but i just kind of wanted to chat
and uh
it's it's it's been a while it doesn't
start for a while we're gonna be we're
gonna be streaming for a bit here
it's gonna be a long stream today uh
it's gonna release in like an hour like
exactly an hour i just thought we could
chat because it's been a while since
i've done a live stream uh
moon night finale was the
was the last live stream i believe i
need to plug my headset in or it's gonna
die
um it starts at 3 a.m eastern time
eastern time
was i plug
ah
yeah it's basically an hour
yes and john prime rebel i think that
the series is off to a really really
really good start like a really good
start
i'm very excited for it
yeah i think the moon night finales were
the moon night finale was the last time
was the last time we did a live stream
so
here's the deal
the miss marvel show
and
kenobi
are are both going to be releasing
next week
at the same time
like exact same time like
tuesday night slash wednesday morning
uh 12 a.m pacific time
um
they're going to come out like the same
time
so
do we want us do we want to do watch
parties for kenobi or miss marvel and um
i kind of want to do kenobi which sounds
weird because i primarily cover marvel
but i enjoy the kenobi series more than
i enjoyed miss marvel
i watched the first two episodes of miss
marvel and the first two episodes of
kenobi and so far kenobi is the clear
winner for me
well i can't really watch them both
because they release at the same t
oliver blue miss kenobi
uh
there's a way to do polls i have not
figured that out yet
how would we do that how would we how
would we do a poll
i think i might have to sign into the
chat on my web browser
uh i know a lot of people are saying why
not do both but guys um
i'm not sure you know how tiring it is
for me
because keep in mind i do
uh breakdowns right after now
i'm not really gonna be doing breakdowns
for kenobi this is going to be one of
those things where i just kind of want
to watch together and enjoy it together
um
hey enchantrix i mean you should watch
star wars they're they're pretty awesome
i i actually am a huge star wars fan
y'all um which is why i'm starting to
talk about it more
i i'm a i'm a big
big star wars fan so we could do a poll
i so all right let's let's do this
should oh
no maybe
there we go should
we do
watch parties for
kanobi
kenobi
or miss marvel
kinobi
miss marvel
pull
i think maybe
is there a poll let me go into my phone
and uh
there we go
all right yes pull i see
i see the pull fill out the pole choose
choose can i vote
i voted
i can vote
oh oh wow hey
mimi olsen welcome to the cosmic fam
memberships are active
they are active we can do
oh i can vote
i can vote for my own poll wow we're
getting a lot for kenobi which is
interesting because my my channel
primarily talks about marvel
i just voted on my phone
that's like inception right there i'm
here i'm here i'm
okay i here he's crushing it yo kenobi's
crushing it
dang
uh black old cheese is there a reason
you just keep typing e
i'm gonna have to time you out if you
keep uh if you keep typing e let's not
spam
man
uh it is not out in nine minutes guys um
it's not an hour and nine minutes
actually it's out in
58 minutes i have hair in my mouth there
it is i got it it's out in 58 minutes
uh because
i came on an hour early just because i
wanted to chat with everybody um
guys it i know a lot of people are
saying like let's do it for both i'm
just gonna be just completely honest i
don't have it in me
um
you know by the time we get watching by
the time we finish watching one of these
it's time
to do a breakdown which takes hours so
by the time like okay for example for
like moon night
loki
one division all those that we've gotten
so far
i go to bed at like 7 8 a.m because i
just i do the watch parties and then i
do the breakdowns after and i'm just
exhausted
i'm just exhausted
and the reason i do the breakdowns like
right away is because i know people like
wait for those
wait for them
so
have i seen str i have not seen stranger
things yet uh james gibson and fimo
thank you i love toys
this is my toy shirt
um
[Music]
i
maybe one well i don't know how long
stranger things is going to be around
um
i'm not going to do it now it's just
kind of too much
and like the thing is with stranger
things that they release them all at
once
and i don't have
the capacity to just sit here and just
watch them all i know a lot of people
binge watch a lot of things
but on camera and in a chair like this
and granted it's a comfortable chair but
it's just a lot to do
it's just it's really really doesn't
like to do a lot to do i haven't even
watched uh
i haven't even watched the new ones yet
i haven't even had time i was at star
wars celebration from wednesday to to
sunday so monday morning was kind of the
first
time i got back and had time to do stuff
and uh yeah yeah miss barbara is getting
killed in the poll and don't get me
wrong guys i
i enjoyed miss marvel um
i still can't review it yet uh the the
embargo which means you can't talk about
it till this date isn't even isn't even
out yet so
you watched all seven hours on discord
that's
that's something
forsaken okay wait hold on
does anybody know whose lightsaber this
is
anybody know whose lightsaber this is
uh i did get to see the trailers of star
wars celebration and i did do a video on
it uh
saturday
yes no yes saturday
i saw the ahsoka footage and i saw the
mandalorian uh
the mandalorian season three guys okay
the mandalorian season three teaser
trailer
was amazing
like it was legitimately
hope we get yoda jin god ahsoka and the
emperor i would be shocked if we didn't
get ahsoka
okay hold on
who's the first
i hope so too lewis and uh thank you for
that super chat
i would be shocked if we didn't at least
get ahsoka okay so hold on who is the
first person to start
a little kickstart i don't know if
you're saying this is amaze windows
lightsaber
i don't know if t rob brown you're
saying this kenobi's
but i think i believe
the master 22 dude you were the first to
say this is ahsoka's lightsaber
and what's really cool about it is if
you
hold some buttons down
it turns green
and then it turns like
a
different green almost like a yellow
but then
i like the blue
it's a nice blue
it's kind of interesting to see on
camera
especially when it's like
trying to focus oh that looks pretty
cool
adam what's up dude
i actually hold it like this
that's kind of cool
yeah so um they only really i see some
people asking this
uh mystic bb uh
um
the episodes do come out tuesday nights
now
the friday release was just like a one
time thing they like changed the date
and then made an announcement like oh
we're gonna move it back like a few days
but don't worry we're gonna give you two
episodes the first day or that we
release it so
yeah
uh
akj thank you for that super chat i
don't think we'll see ob face vader in
this episode he just reconnected with
the force and isn't quite fit enough to
face him in my opinion yeah i agree with
you and if i think if they did
obi would get clapped
um
who knows
but i'm with you i don't i don't i don't
think we'll see it i don't think we'll
see it thank you for that super chat
lewis another one thank you so much
lewis barry i just want a vader movie
yeah
that would be really cool
that would be really cool
well broden if you were first i
apologize
kudos to you give you a little shout out
there broden
hey may the force be with youtube mystic
what's up master studios please don't
spam please don't spam guys
uh is it 30 minutes till release no it's
about
50 minutes to release
i would be an awesome jedi
kind of loose
this one's better oh
i think i fixed it
hey the star wars guy you saw me you
should have said hi and yeah wendy we
are
me and wendy are like best friends
we went to the twice show together
um and her husband or yeah her husband
dustin is super awesome as well yeah
michael connolly um
disney decided to give us the first two
episodes on friday but then they decided
to uh
uh
just do like a normal release which i'm
bummed about because now we have to like
we do have to choose we have to choose
between kenobi or miss marvel we have to
choose because i'm sorry i don't
maybe we can do both maybe we can go
back to back
but then i can't do a breakdown of miss
marvel like right away like i straight
up can't do that it's just gonna be too
much
it really is
lloyd dixon i've met eric voss i've
known him for a while now actually
i've uh where's the first time i met him
oh well i was on new rockstar's uh show
like two years ago i guess that would be
the first time i met him hey
i didn't turn you off there we go uh
and then i saw him
i saw him at miss no eternals i saw him
at the eternals premiere
and that was first time i got to talk in
person because i went on the show during
the pandemic
so we didn't meet face to face
um
i don't i don't know i don't
i don't want to say too much about miss
marvel because i firmly believe
that people should form their own
opinions
um
so i like really hate
saying if i like something or not before
it comes out
or like giving it a rating because i
don't i don't want people to go in with
like a certain expectation
um
yeah
i mean
i don't want to like either ruin
something or like set too high
expectations i will say if i find
something to be stop it
i will say if i find something to be
like
truly amazing i typically
won't be able to keep
my mouth shut about it um
i'll typically be like shang chi my
reaction was like yo this is a
masterpiece because yo that's top tier
marvel to me i love shang chi that's an
amazing movie to me um
some people don't know i was raised by a
korean family when i was younger
partially
my family is fantastic
but my my dad and my mom worked a lot
and my dad worked out of
state
so like the family down the road pretty
much raised me for
for a while so
i did a bunch of martial arts
up until i was like 20 something years
old
uh
so
i love martial arts and i love asian
culture
um
so champion to me was amazing
it was amazing yeah we have about an
hour guys actually no we have 48 minutes
because they always release them at
11 50
pacific time
what shirt is this it's twice twice as a
k-pop group
uh they're my favorite ever i love all
of them i just saw them like three weeks
ago with forsaken my mod in the chat
forsaken did you say something and i and
i missed it i feel like
oh it's a great yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i loved i love chongqing
who would win
is tcw the cosmic wonder
ben vs talking ben i'm not really sure
what that uh
i'm not really sure what the julio perez
are you the julio perez i know because i
know julio perez
are you
julio i just that's why i call him julia
yeah yeah yeah uh release time see a
bunch of people asking
got about 47 minutes i just thought we
would go live and talk a little bit
because it's been a while
and i'm in uh so i actually
now
uh starting next week i will have a
place in l.a so i live in mountain time
and
but since i'm in la so much now
it just made sense to to rent a place
there
so
what is the figure under my shelf under
the play button
that is captain america
and that is a
special
dorbz
pop that my friend gave me
does that answer your question
uh mr anderson will be here forsaken's
great but mr anderson will be here i
started a little early i'm sure he
wasn't ready for that um
so yeah hey brandon what's up dude i see
you see you i see you
did i eliminate her i called clone
stormtroopers
i mean
depending on what time error you are and
they are clones
i'm not wrong
[Laughter]
my bad sometimes so a lot of people
think i script my videos i don't i just
talk i have bullet points on my
computers
but i just talk
i'm gonna try something hold on
it didn't work
i wonder why this isn't working
oh it's because it has a cap on
it i'm stupid
oh that's funny you can see okay hold on
so i have
another face cam i thought it would be
cool to do like different
though the lighting though hold on
that the lighting for the other face
can't oh
it's still too much
dang all right we'll switch back to the
other one
now it's a little dark
oh too much
too much
that's fine
oh
mr anderson's here hello mr anderson i
decided to start a little bit early just
because we haven't
uh
we haven't been uh
on here in a while
do i use bots to grow my channel
absolutely not i'm offended
everything has been organic the only
thing i've done
is giveaways
and i stopped doing those
because
i didn't want people just to subscribe
for the giveaways
but i am going to do them again because
i do think my subs deserve
to be treated
um
that's why i like i i did like um
the hex instagram how did i forget that
that's why i did like instagram
giveaways for a while because i'm like
well if you know you're a fan of the
channel and everything like that then
like in
most people have instagram i understand
that some people don't
most people do
um
i figured you know if you follow me on
there like you're you're supportive
channel so
uh
so yeah uh
there's a question i saw in here that
i've been that i've seen a lot so i want
to uh
i want to address it
that 13 year old if want to teleport it
away where do you think she went i think
she went somewhere
remote
kind of
kind of maybe like she had at the end of
one division except now she's free of
corruption now
now she doesn't
have the dark hole kind of like
whispering in her ear and now maybe
she's
let go just a little bit
um
you know like let go just a little bit
has accepted
has accepted
that she won't get her kids if you don't
stop turning off
there's not much i can do about it
so
i hope that answers your question i
think she went somewhere and found
solitude
part one is better than part two
referring to what
let viria yeah that would be interesting
what is a good g-fuel flavor the moon
knight one is really good
the moon knight one is real i am using
my elgato stuff uh this lightsaber is
kind of screwing with the camera and
everything
there we go
but uh i can control
everything here with the
with uh
my stream deck so like if i wanted to
like really just like amp up the lights
i could
i won't be able to see but i could
i can control all my lighting with the
with the stream deck which is really
cool
let's put it up just a little bit more
there we go
warren is the new hope that's funny
uh
ot blakey thank you so much appreciate
that
um
thoughts on the moses engram situation
um
bad like
have you already okay so
i hear a lot of people telling me um
asking to talk about star wars
celebration which i will i also feel
like we have
too much light now
there we go
um star wars celebration so so so disney
first of all the most single situation
like just
no one should be racist like
i think it's pretty simple
like
don't be racist don't hate somebody
because collab their skin i feel like
that's
not bad heart
but you know that's the world we live in
um
i hope we see fake jedi again i hope we
see camille nanjiani again
um
jeff
so
star wars celebration was
so cool
and disney flew me out they invited me
they put uh
they put me in a hotel
a nice hotel um
they gave me a per diem
for food they hooked me up
disney is awesome
uh there's a lot of good that comes with
disney um when they're people
uh
oh did you
were you really that star wars guy were
you really that's so funny i got the
frosted flakes right here
let me grab them is my headset connect
yeah hold on
that's so funny
check it out
obi-wan kenobi frosted flakes
boom
got those at star wars celebration
because wendy from the movie couple
she uh
she got picked to go on stage to do uh
like a competition but that's so funny
that star wars guy didn't even know dang
you should have said hi dang man
uh
so yeah i remind you of reed richards
leonardo that's like
the best compliment i've ever gotten in
my life
uh but so yeah so star wars celebration
i flew in wednesday i flew home
sunday night very late like 12. um
it started thursday and since we have a
lot of new people in here i
i will say that the probably like the
coolest thing to happen was like so star
wars celebration like you go in the main
state uh the main you know room because
there's like
there's a celebration stage which is the
main stage and then there's like two
other places where they stream it to but
i was there where like everything
actually was taken down uh there's a
reserve section for the media which is
what i am
and um
so we sat down got our seats and there's
like a dj playing in the beginning so
it's like really really cool and then uh
you know there's like a
like an mc with him that's on stage
doing you know talking about stuff and
um
so it starts
and it it's like this uh choir comes out
singing and there's like a bunch of it's
like all red on them you know like sith
and stuff like that um
and then
ewan mcgregor and hayden christensen
walk out on stage
and
oh the first thing he says is hello
there and it's like
the greatest thing ever it's like the
greatest thing ever so
so yeah
uh star wars celebration next year is in
london i don't know if disney's gonna do
the same thing and fly me out and all
that stuff that would be super awesome a
trip to london would be fantastic so uh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so
uh yeah guys hey let's not talk about
like politics and stuff i understand
that was a star wars question and uh
you know people should just like i'm
this is like my theory and everything
you should just be kind to other people
like unless somebody is actively trying
to harm you or anything like that like i
always say like do what makes you happy
as long as it's not harming people or
like bug in the world
i think it's a pretty simple philosophy
that i live by
you know so
whatever
so let's not uh
let's not talk about the politics in
here so
i could be the illuminati iron man
you guys are coming up the compliments
today i love it
uh
wish the marvel and star wars show could
feel as tight as the movies um
i think the shows i think
i think the disney plush shows
offer
something that the movies don't and
that's just like a lot of story
right whereas you would have to
rush the story in a movie
because i've watched movies where i
think that the stories should have
played out a little bit more like let's
turn the screen
uh
so
i like doctor trains a multiverse of
madness i felt could have used a little
bit more story
i liked it a lot i loved it um
it's up there with one of the better
ones so
and they did use disney plus for that
like if you didn't watch one division
you had no idea
what was going on
and well
yeah i mean you really
missed out on a lot from multiverse of
madness i think they might have like
they touched a little bit about her
trying to get her kids and and dr
strange is like
they're not real like so it's like
you you really missed out on a lot so
disney plus gives us opportunities yes
there have been some misses with disney
plus they're not all hits you know
hit or miss you know i guess they never
miss
but they do miss sometimes sean bell
thank you for that super chat what do
you want to see in part three i wish for
one lightsaber duel doesn't have to be
ob invader just yet i
i would hope so i would hope we would
get a lightsaber duel
um
maybe with one of the inquisitors uh
maybe with sister three uh
and obi-wan i do want more lightsaber
duels
and i believe we were told we are going
to get more of like the
episode 3
lightsaber styles which you know i'm
here for
um
so
yeah yeah yeah
i'm hoping for the same hope for the
same
yeah cn1 division was pretty much like
if you like you pretty much had to like
i i'm saying you don't have to because
they kind of explain it but if you
didn't you really missed out on a lot of
enjoyment of the movie i mean
like really it should have been 40
minutes longer it should have slowed
down a little bit
and they cut about 40 minutes and i
don't know why but
that's them
tom hardy is the wolverine owen
mcgregor's professor x christopher waltz
has magneto
that's pretty good lewis i'm not even
gonna lie that's that's pretty dang good
casting right there i really really like
that
louis berry thanks for that super chat
uh guitar hero wwe duh
uh i like lego star wars on ps5 i i
really do um i've always enjoyed
uh the lego games you know uh so yeah no
i'm i'm all for those
what is the poll at
83 kenobi
is there a way to like
can i
send it out again i guess it's on i
guess like when you yeah it's like there
when you
when you just go on to the live it's
just there
so i guess i don't really need to
yeah i guess i don't really need to do
anything so
fine by me
i just want to make sure
but everything seems to be working right
so cool cool cool cool
it's interesting that so many people are
choosing kenobi but i will say again as
somebody who's seen miss marvel
i would rather do kenobi
if i was in a star wars world
would you be a jedi or sith um
it's it's like so funny because you
gotta put like a real life scenario on
it because i feel like
um
turn on
i feel like like the sith are really
cool but i also feel like the jedi are
really cool i would be a jedi
um
or maybe i'd be like ahsoka
you know like maybe you're like
not either
but you are like
i mean i have ahsoka's lightsaber
so
leonardo
i do think obi-wan is going to
communicate with qui-gon i actually
thought that was going to happen in
the first second episode i don't
remember
um
mando question who do you think's safe
grogo in the temple
it's not ruled out yet that like
they didn't actually like the
stormtroopers didn't actually grab him i
think they might have actually grabbed
him now did somebody save him after that
probably um
i
i thought we would i honestly thought
we'd see mace windu
maybe show up
um said we got cod bain which i'm like
totally cool with because he's freaking
awesome and he looked amazing
um
i was a background actor for godzilla
versus calm because they're filming in
my area knocked my door and asked i want
to be a background actor when you've
said yes
dang that's pretty cool even if they
didn't pay you got story now
i love ahsoka and i saw rosario dawson
she was like
10 foot away from me that was pretty
crazy
um
yeah i i don't want to say miss marvel
is childish it's definitely for a
younger audience though i will say that
it's
and it's for like
people in high school you know what i
mean like
yeah
convent you would fold so easily and
become a sith that's the question man
like we don't really know what would you
do in a given situation because like the
path of the jedi is really really hard
you can't have a relationship you know
it's hard
rashkind one yes i am a huge once i saw
i've seen twice three times
front row each time i love it could i do
tricks with the saber yeah but i'll
break everything in my room
to be perfectly honest so uh
but i actually the martial arts
like my whole life i've done martial
arts for like a really long time
so i've uh i've practiced with certain
weapons and stuff so
does that does that kind of answer your
question as i'm sitting here in the
chair i can do this which i'm pretty
sure everybody in the world can do and
then i can turn the other way but i
would break everything
maybe one day i'll have to do like a
vlog
and like beat up my brother or something
the jedi path or sauna sauna all day
i would choose sana and momo over like
anything i would choose any one from
twice pretty much over anything
a grey jedi yeah daniel
i i like miss windu mace windu and
purple is my favorite color too i saw
somebody say that
um
star wars was brought up in civil war
too and captain america civil war
do i remember that
i don't remember that
look kaz janick um
so the first martial arts i ever did was
tong tsudo which is a korean martial art
because of case you mentioned this when
i was younger i was pretty much raised
by korean family so that's that's what i
did um
the second one
i ever did i believe was taekwondo
um as i got older i started to
the next one was kung fu and i studied
at a very very authentic uh
chinese temple
after that i did
aikido and then after that i did mma
style fighting so
those are what i've been been trained on
it was when i did
a keto is what i trained with
weapons and a tiny bit kung fu with kung
fu you really have to progress
um for to actually hit somebody like a
lot of its form and stuff like that um
so to actually be able to spy with
somebody and like use or practice with
weapons in kung fu you have to really
really progress
i do love twice yes j-ron
i freaking love toys
uh
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes with the
walking thingies yes yes start yes okay
yes i remember i remember i remember
i remember
um
i don't
mr anderson you want to grab a link for
my k-pop channel
so for those of you who like k-pop
because i'm seeing a lot of people who
like k-pop i actually sing covers of
some kpop songs that i like and i
started a k-pop channel
if you want to follow it i'm sure most
people don't but
singing is kind of my passion and k-pop
is kind of my passion so i put two
together
gary phillips what's up man it's been a
while been subscribed to your channel
for a long time i hope you're doing well
boss man hey i really appreciate that
appreciate that always uh love the
support thank you for that super chat
been doing well last week was star wars
celebration and i am very tired um and i
have a headache and
i had to cancel going to the miss marvel
premiere
on thursday because a lot of people got
covered
and so you guys want to hear a story so
check out this story
so
as i mentioned um
disney flew me out for star wars
celebration and they got me the hotel
and they they did everything they took
care of they took care of everything um
so
they picked me up in a car and there was
about six people there's about six or
seven of us getting to the airport at
the same time
so when they picked me up when i got in
la they picked us up in like a really
big
mercedes sprinter van
so
that was fun but then uh
on the way back there was just two of us
going to the airport is this lady that i
know she's
uh she's very nice i just met her
um but we had great great conversation
and
uh we exchanged info because we both
kind of do the same thing
and
i got an email from her this morning
that says
hey i have covid and i was literally so
they picked us up in just uh like a
mercedes car and we were both sitting in
the back seat so she was like literally
like right here next to me now we were
both wearing masks
um
and then we but then we like we were
with each other in the airport where we
took off our masks when we were just
sitting down and eating and chilling and
uh
so i might have covered just
from freaking
being around her which isn't you know
her fault she didn't know
she hadn't so
but yeah okay yeah so there's the link
to my
cover k-pop channel i don't know if i
can actually bring it up and show it on
the stream because
it still technically is me singing a
cover song
so i don't know if it'll get copyrighted
like i i really don't let me say hold on
how do i do this what's going on
right screen
yeah
i can i can this is a black pink song
that i that i covered
i don't think you can actually hear
yeah you can't hear it so
but this is it and it's just like my
name so if you want to
if you want to
give that a follow only if you like it i
don't expect you to follow my covered
channel if you uh
if you don't like it so don't even worry
about that i don't know why you can't
hear it though that's actually going to
be a problem um
because if we because we you know
bring chris in here after how's that
gonna work how
audio
why can't i
why can't i hear that that's actually a
problem
[Music]
yikes
that's not good
can y'all hear that
can you guys hear that
can we hear that no i don't
oh thank you guitar hero you're so kind
this is blackpink but i can you guys
hear that because that's gonna be a
problem for uh
after the stream
yes no can we can we hear it yes no
no yeah okay uh
that's gonna have to change
how do i change that
this has to be with your headset
i don't know what that means
i'm not getting
it should be desktop audio
this is gonna be an issue and i don't
know how to fix it
okay
well
do that for a second
audio input capture what are you tell me
what you are
desktop
audio
device
oh so if i
if i do that does it work
it does work
that is me singing
so if you want to
[Music]
subscribe
this is kind of like a
more of a rap song
so
[Music]
it's funny because i didn't think i'd
actually
show people this then my friends started
posting it on
like social media and stuff so i was
like yeah
i just threw it on there
it is
but i'm afraid since this is not my own
song that it will actually be
copyrighted so
we're not going to go through that but
if
if k-pops your thing or music's your
thing um
excuse me that's not a good coveted sign
is it
uh yeah um
[Music]
hey thanks brandon hey thanks lewis uh
who just asked
alex carrillo
are me and ali related no so
i met ali in orlando uh chris and i met
her at the same time
uh at our church
and uh
i forced them together
we would like be playing sports and
stuff and i like walk by
like chris and i'd like shove him into
her so he like went up
like literally that's what i would do
and i i would uh i would like like dude
you have to go on a date with her you
gotta go you gotta go on a date with
you're gonna gonna get date with her
like you have to so
i take credit for putting them together
but chris who edits from my channel and
who uh runs cosmic culture
he's married to ali and we were all
roommates for years like uh chris and i
were started to become roommates about
ooh maybe yeah about four years ago
and then ally
became my roommate about
three
two and a half years ago and then um
they just moved like a couple months ago
really really sad they moved back to
florida to be with their family
so yeah
so yeah
more covers will be coming to that
channel very soon uh the next one
or maybe i shouldn't say
maybe maybe i shouldn't say
the next cover maybe it should be a
surprise
maybe should be a surprise
so matchmaker i i
i would say i'm a pretty good wingman
fruit
i was pretty decent wingman
thanks alex
yeah
try to try to help help my friends out i
like to consider myself a good friend
speaking of i
should probably check my text because
some of my friends were texting me about
some serious stuff
all right
we are pretty close we're about
15 minutes away
how is the pole doing i'm actually
eighty-three percent for kenobi yeah i'm
tired
three percent for kenobi
show the cat
rocket
hi rocket
what you doing
you like the lightsaber
it's not real
i don't know if that's good for your
eyes babe
we see the cat
she's trying to get the lightsaber
well she got oh she's biting it
don't bite the lightsaber
oh
i'm sorry didn't mean to hit you
whoop whoop
poke
i love her she's
i have another cat around here somewhere
her name is kyrie named after uh kyrie
from kingdom hearts she is rocket named
after rocket raccoon from i mean i think
everybody here should know who rocket
racoon is uh
yes i love cats um what is my opinion
what my opinion what is my opinion on
the upcoming
dc universe with new merger can we
expect as much as marvel no uh
i i wouldn't ever
i want to expect as much as marvel or i
should say i want to hope
that one day there's
there's good as marvel
do as much as marvel i think
it's sad to say i think it needs a
complete reboot and i say it's sad to
say because like i love gal gadot or
gagado i'm
people always say i say it wrong no
matter how i say it so
um i'm gonna say gagado um people always
say
that
it needs a reboot i agree um
i
if they rebooted it i would keep her as
wonder woman
um
i would keep the rock as black adam
although i haven't seen him as black
adam yet i i'm i'm going to assume he's
going to do a good job
uh he's i love the rock so much but
there are some rolls that you know
you know it could have been better but
uh i did g fuel i'm so tired
and i really hope i don't have coveted
but i did have to cancel the
going to the miss marvel premiere
but i am going to the
uh light year premiere buzz lightyear
and i get to go to the after party for
that so maybe i'll meet chris evans
ah thanks daniel bergen i hope i hope
i'm a good friend
ah you have a cat called groot t rob
brown that's awesome
uh yeah hunter i don't think marvel's
gonna buy dc out i don't think warner
brothers would ever do that
i just think
this is very not what you do with a real
lightsaber
i just think
uh just a reboot with some clear
cut
like defined parameters for what the
heck they're doing
is needed or just make one off films i'm
okay with that
yes guitar hero i would still have jason
momoa as aquaman as well um
hmm
i like joker that was great as a one-off
thing i really like the batman
i really really like batman
yeah the flash on cw's is really good um
yeah
oh thank you
i think it was bob who said that for
you bob schwartz my chair it's iron man
yeah i don't bend very well there you go
rock it
broke it
hey
is this camera better it's gonna look
weird but
nope that's not it
there you go rocket
hey
hey hey you
hey
she's not she's taking a bath she's not
having it right now
she don't care
are fans allowed to go to marvel
premieres or do you have to be invited
chaz d bianco thanks for that uh super
chat you have to be invited it's very
uh what's the word
exclusive that's the word
yeah you have to be invited
and at first when i got promoted i
didn't even get a guest and now i get a
guest so i guess i'm moving up in the
world and now i'm invited to like other
premieres i typically try
let's go back to the other camera
i typically try to
not accept
like premier invitations and stuff
unless i'm going to talk about it
because that's you know that's the whole
deal well you know it's like
obviously like marvel
disney anything disney that they do like
it just kind of like it's like
for them they want like the social
influencers and youtubers and all that
stuff they want um
just them to be seen there
but like i get invited to like a lot of
other premieres like a lot of pixar
premieres like turning red and stuff
like that and i'm i just tell them like
hey i'm not going to cover this like
i don't want to take up a seat take up a
premiere ticket because i'm not going to
cover it so but i'm going to light you
and i will do a review on light year um
for those of you wondering about marvel
content it's not going anywhere i'm just
adding more content because i
like a lot of stuff and for the while
i'm not gonna lie i was scared to do
other things
um every now and every time i would do a
different video that wasn't marvel
um it would even it would be like the
second video i did of that day like do a
marvel video and then do another video
it was like on dc and people would be
like if you do dc i'm unsubscribing and
that kind of scared me at first but like
you know what i
i want to talk about what i want to talk
about and i'm always going to want to
talk about marvel so that's never going
to go away anything big that happens in
marvel's always going to be a priority
but you know what i like just cinema in
general so i'm
gonna talk about some other stuff i like
hope everybody
can get on board with that and if you
don't like want to watch the dc stuff
you don't have to just keep watching the
marvel stuff
but yet some people are like nope
unsubscribing so whatever
um
i don't know
if i'm going to d23 in orlando orlando's
touching my hometown it's where my mom
lives and my sister and her family lives
so i'd love to be invited
by disney
i gotta talk to them about that
what's really cool is that like
that's an interesting comment daniel the
joker is your role model gotta watch out
for you huh
uh
do what you like the real ones but yeah
i mean
yeah cat like bath damn yeah uh yeah and
like
don't get me wrong i understand that
there are some people that are like
warren's the marvel guy and the second i
start adding more stuff it's like he's
not like
exclusively the marvel guy anymore and
that may put some people off and i'm
sorry but i'm always gonna be the marvel
guy like because i love marvel more than
anything but you know what i really like
star wars and i just like watching
movies and shows in general so
pretty much israel dawson she's like
leave me alone rock it
poop
she is the sweetest cat i love her
with all my heart if i can love a woman
uh with like half as much as i love her
that woman's gonna be like the luckiest
lady in the planet i love rocket so
heart so much she's the sweetest cat
she follows me everywhere she
looks my nose looks my face cuddles up
next to me um when she dies i'm gonna
just
be a mess i'm gonna be a wreck and she's
pretty old so
she's like 11 years old
ah thanks jess i appreciate that
uh
exclusive as in like you have to be
we you have to be invited to a premiere
there are very
exclusive event um not just anybody you
know can can go like uh they do have
like uh they have a section that's like
uh sectioned off for like fans who are
all like cosplayed and stuff i don't
know how
they get invited
um
i know a guy
that's like in one of those groups
because he stopped me at a few premieres
and it's like hey you're worn because i
wonder take a picture i'm like yeah
obviously let's do it um he said he's in
a group
so maybe you could like google that
because i i'm not a part of that group
so
yeah so i find comics go together it's
nerd content that's that's my thing it's
like
i like nerdy things i like star wars i
like batman
i'm not gonna be talking about
you know like
i'm not gonna ever talk about the saw
movies and you can
clip it or record this for future
purposes in case i ever do i actually
don't like gore or horror stuff uh so i
never will but you know i'm gonna be
talking about that stuff i'm gonna be
talking about relative things also six
minutes
oh i should pull up uh
disney plus
canobie
hello there
daniel radcliffe the superman
i honestly would pay money to see that
because he's shorter than i am and i'm
like 5 8.
on a good day
kubota takes um
any advice for you aspiring content
creator
be
decide what you want to do
and i and i mean decide
and be consistent at it
a lot of people
ask me a lot of people ask me for advice
and they say i tried really hard at
youtube and then i go
define
trying really hard
and they go like well
i posted like
once a week or like a few times a month
for like four months and i'm like it's
not trying really at all
uh
like you can post once a week or a few
times a month but you have to do that
for a very long time i posted
two times a day
for like six months every single day
sometimes i would only post once a day
but i never missed a day
like
and i still i take sundays off now
because i need some sanity in my life
but uh
i i i never missed a day like the first
six months like that's what you have to
do so i mean it like be consistent
don't stop and if it's something that
you really want to do like just go for
it like i quit my job when i started
doing youtube and i had you know a nice
career as a financial advisor but i
decided this is what i wanted to do
so i did it
and i went all in and i worked hard and
i was consistent and i tried to improve
and i still try to improve every day and
if you just do that
you should be successful i am nothing
special
i i mean that i didn't i
i pay for my mother's rent right now i
did not come from a rich family
i just told you that a korean family had
to help take care of me because we were
poor like i am nothing special i just
decided i wanted to do something and i
loved something enough to want to talk
about it
and i stuck with it
anyone could do it literally anybody
could do it anyone could do it i'm not
telling you to quit your job or anything
like that but because i'm not
responsible for that
that is what i did though because i
decided i wanted it so
if you want to do something if it's
truly what you want to do
uh get good at it be consistent with it
it should work out because if i can do
it anybody can so
yeah mr anderson i'll be looking out for
that i'm sure you'll let me know when
obviously so
ah thanks joe jose civilian
to be um thank you
yeah
thanks louis
uh
is it out i don't have it out yet
yeah cole
yeah and like i said like some people
are like well i don't have time
well plus when you have time but but the
the deal is is you can't quit after
nothing happens in three months i did it
for six months posting twice a day and i
didn't get anything until six months and
it was like a 30 000 view video right
but four years later
all my videos pretty much get at least
30 000 views so it's you know it's it's
there's fun in the journey it's hard to
see at the time
but there is fun in the journey uh you
can't connect the dots in life you know
looking forward you can only connect
them looking backwards and i see
where everything connected but you just
gotta
you just have to want it
well thanks mr anderson i
i do it well because i worked at it
right and even to this day i try to
improve because i look at like new rock
stars and i'm like they're fantastic
like
i'm like i'm nothing like new rock stars
like i need to get better
um and eric voss is a friend of mine and
so is philip molina and tommy like i'm
really good friends with new rock stars
i i'm friends with paul from heavy
spoilers like i
i'm one of those guys that gets along
with anybody as long as you don't do
anything to me like oh i'm cool you know
what i mean like do you all do me
we're good
uh but just
decide you want something and go for it
you know what i mean and if that's
posting once a month make that video
that you post every month freaking good
right because that way people will look
forward to that once a month
and they'll be like
i know this next video is going to be
fire because he puts a lot of attention
and detail and a lot into that video
so
but don't quit after three months is all
i'm saying right you gotta go like if
it's something you truly want like years
like you gotta i was fortunate enough to
where uh
at like the end of my first year i
started to be able to actually make
money doing this so
but i wouldn't have quit if i didn't
so i did youtube for six months without
getting paid because it was right when
the
the monetization
uh
guidelines changed it used to be like
you have to have
10 000 views total that's it
something like that
my cat
there's rocket
rocket
hi
there babies
i just realized i have my tripod here
all right is it out
uh i'm not gonna interrupt i'm not gonna
grab it or bring it to the camera
she's chilling but that's my cat and i
love her
that's ruckette
uh
episode three is out
it's just called part three
oh i need a timer
what do i type stop watch is that what i
type in normally
stop watch there it is
let's pop this out in a new window
why can't i move in a new window
why can't i pop this on a new window
what's going on
what can i do come on new window
whatever i'll just open a new window
okay
wait how many windows do i have oh it's
because i already have a new window open
whoopsie okay so disney plus
yo i'm hella excited for this
obi-wan
we move you here
cool all right uh
we are going to start this in three
two
one
we have started it
where's my timer
there well that's too big
a girl has been kidnapped i need to find
her out of the way you're never going to
see her again
nobody leaves this place
there's a jedi he helps people
they're doing a recap and they're just
showing camille nanjiani which i
thoroughly enjoyed
oh crap oh you can hear the audio let's
not
let's not do that because that's how you
get
copyrighted
your father sent me
trashbot did you do a super chat i'm so
sorry hold on let me look at it up
brad bird for fantastic four edgar
wright for x-men
i like that hold on i'm gonna look at
all the
trash boat i'm so sorry you think we'll
ever get darth maul's standalone project
with the knight says dude i would love
that
i would freaking love that so sorry i
didn't see that so sorry i didn't see
that but thank you so much i really
appreciate that i would love it
i think it would be in the wheelhouse
to actually happen to
sorry i missed that dude
and there's vader
yo
let's freakin do this
all right this episode
is about 47 minutes long
star wars
my sound's not on anymore is it
my chat's not moving for some reason i
i can't
huh he's trying to touch
quite gone
dude we're gonna see qui-gon by the end
of this
let's turn the lights down a little bit
oh dude it's a good spitter here we go
here we go here we go
no oh my gosh look we're seeing like
everything
oh his arms aren't on
then you're my enemy
um
dude
this is insane
help me quit master qui-gon
no it's not mod only i think it's good
the helmet's coming up coming on the
helmet's coming on
oh
dude
the breathing
he's coming master he knows oh my gosh
yo they're just going right into vader i
love it
yo is he are they still there
no
wow
is this james earl jones
and the position of grand inquisitor is
yours
no
love it fail me and you will not live to
regret regret it regret it i'm a child
dude i love that we're getting so much
vader right away look at that his throne
oh
yeah is it james earl jones
did he come back for this i
can't you use the force or something
how does it work
oh that's really cool
no way
that's the that's like the coolest thing
i've ever heard
lullaby
anyone seen the movie flubber with robin
williams it reminds me of that floaty
thing
dude
that's the way to describe the force
been afraid of the dark when you turn on
the lights you feel safe that's what it
feels like dude
i love that wow
wow yeah it sounds like james earl jones
that it's like a spot on voice if it's
not james earl jones
congratulations and well done to the
person who did that voice
what's up adam
we just started
we're seven minutes into it and already
this episode is phenomenal
vader freaking oh
yeah little leia
there was talks at star wars convention
it's like move over baby yoda baby leia
is here now
so
quarantine machine i've never seen
batteries not included i've heard of it
but i mean it still kind of looks like
the thing from flubber right
knights of the old republic vibes
uh israel two vibes
so where are they at now camille
nanjiana's little fake
uh
fake jedi sent him somewhere
lapuzzo
he's on edge
storm troopers
we're gonna
we're gonna look at the
in credits and see if it's james or just
i'll be one sense of something
bro is it qui-gon no oh
dude it's hayden christensen
is he hallucinating
he caught him she caught him ben that's
funny
he's not gonna be there
it's getting to him
is that
is that vader
who is this
oh it's her okay
aries
he's gonna be tossed around round one
yeah for real
it's cool that we actually saw hayden
christensen though
even if it was
him playing force games
yo this visually
oof is just fantastic
they're not in charge here fifth brother
oh
i'm next in line
use some force back at her adam
oh
you're not gonna disobey lord vader are
you
so who are the first two sisters if
she's the third
i want to know her backstory with kenobi
uh david sanchez i don't know if miss
marvel is going to flop i i enjoyed it i
i was entertained but i think a lot of
people
might not like it
it appeals to a younger audience
but i'm along i'm here for the ride
i will say amman does a very very good
job at playing miss marvel
you're my daughter and you don't talk
you don't talk
that's the coordinates so
yo i'll be
on edge
because vader's alive
we're gonna need
some oh
he seems friendly you know it's a car
you don't know
remember you don't talk
you don't talk leia
i know that voice
hello there say it
um
yeah snoop frog
i i loved it
i love that opening with darth vader
oh
hunter i don't remember where they said
they were it's not menon though
but
uh-oh
be one get that white zipper up bro got
some storm troopers
oh snap
hello
no she doesn't sound like she's 10 at
all
uh israel
huh
just do i am not the jedi you're looking
for
i knew it it's a long ride i knew i was
gonna say that
uh-oh
he caught her lair
oh
stormtroopers are smart now huh
oh
[Music]
oh he sees padme
right the feels
dude good good call obi-wan oh that's
thinking on your feet the stormtroopers
are smarter now i feel
yeah she is supposed to sound like she's
uh
she is supposed to sound like she's you
know more mature you know she grows up
to be
you know leia
i mean she has leia but the way that we
know
you knew my real mother she's so smart
you've been hiding something oh
are you my real father
i love it
oh
she's so disappointed
just trying to imagine darth vader
oh this is deep
oh
oh
okay
say we talked about would you you know
join the jedi or you know i think i'd be
like a gray jedi
i'd be like a soaker or
something uh-oh
it's about to happen
ah thanks doodle misery
i appreciate that
i think you might want to check them out
don't put the hood on that's like what
jedi do
[Laughter]
i am not the person you're looking for
that stormtrooper looks beat up protocol
23
yo get that lightsaber ready obi
oh
oh there's a drawer oh
about to go down
raise your head
oh
get him
pull out the lightsaber
oh
could block all of it
what
dude the guy just got cut in half that
was awesome
that was awesome
yo
hey david sanchez seems like super chat
dude this show is amazing
dude that guy got cut right in half
you can walk around it
uh oh
dude pull out the lightsaber obi-wan
come on
you can take him
you are jedi master
here we go oh
plot twist
interesting
now is this a trap
mapuzo that's where they're at somebody
asked me that
this signal came before
impact he's there
apprecia oh you dirty little rat
kill him
just kill him who cares let's kill him
yo david sanders did you donate again
no but still very much appreciated
oh that sucks shadow fox i would just
keep trying man it's a great episode man
just keep trying
they locked everything
um
i didn't mean to run away
oh
leia's gonna get home
i need obi-wan to take out his freaking
lightsaber
did the woman tell you to wait there
oh she caught him
oh l0la lola
oh
my droid friends
and who are you
who's we
the rebel alliance i guess
we'll hear the other jedi to come
through
beam
oh
she's definitely force insensitive
inquisitors
can you truly see
cool
i think this is going to end with leia
using some type of
maybe force but no i don't think so
because she doesn't she does it in any
of the
original ones
they don't ever check in there until
they do check in there
i thought i thought they can't
communicate oh does he ever oh he's got
a hammer
oh snap
i was going to say they don't even allow
them communicating he's talking to it
like it's going to communicate with them
also these stormtroopers look rough
like they are freaking dirty
yo this guy about to throw that hammer
like thor
we're not ready i don't care
uh is that the droid from rogue one oh i
don't think so no
is she a jedi
huh
yeah she will
interesting
[Music]
tyler
she's legit she better not die i bet you
she's about to die
what is up booby pun
booby punk number
do you feel
anakin
no
he's there
it's vader
he's there
lightsaber
can i tell the question again i'm not
sure what the question is
yo vader in the whose
i'm actually surprised how much video
they showed on this episode
is he gonna sense you uh i think he did
just sent you
he
he knows he knows that
that obi-wan won't let him kill somebody
he what are you gonna do obi-wan oh no
the little boy's there too
you just killed that kid and that dad
yo anakin has not stopped killing
younglings holy crap
wow i cannot believe
we just saw that happen
he's gonna kill her too you're just
gonna let people die
grab your bloody lightsaber and do
something
he knows he's there
oh
yo
anakin has not
stopped killing younglings
y'all need to run
did y'all see him just snap those
people's necks and freaking just
just with the force like it goes nothing
run no you turn back on
so i'm assuming obi-wan kenobi is
running away from light because vader
can send him
[Laughter]
oh my gosh pull out the light server
yes
come on
i just want to see you fight
[Laughter]
oh
dude that was crazy cool
you think you're just gonna run away
from him
run
yes he's got it he's got it out
yo they're about to fight
yo he is haunted by him
what have you become
what you made me
you have done that yourself
they are teasing us holy crap they are
teasing us
they are teasing us
lightsaber battle
i don't want to die and i feel like she
is gonna die
i also feel like she might be a jedi
though no because she said she started
with the empire
maybe she's force sensitive
no he didn't say that um
vader said like i am what you made me
and i was i just threw that line out
there
because i mean he obi-wan didn't make
him vader
palpatine made him vader
bad choices made him vader that's why i
said like anakin should or obi-wan
should have said you have done that
yourself
no yes they're fighting oh
dude we're getting it we're getting it
fight ben
made you weak i knew he was gonna say
something about him being weak
does she sense it
yo could she be force sensitive
well she's about to run into the
revolution
oh this is crazy this is awesome we're
definitely watching this over miss
marvel sorry
bring him back
this music and every oh my gosh
ob
come on
oh he force pushed him
i mean he kind of thought he did kill
you
ah please don't
die i don't want to see tala die
oh she's seeing the market
surprise
come on leia you should run faster you
out ran those two fully grown men in the
other sea
he's gonna oh
obi-wan
you gotta you gotta bring it back you
gotta search inside you man
i mean it's been 10 years invaders just
trained
yo
he's gonna
he's gonna he's gonna try to do to him
what
how he burned
do something bad
oh
can't you just bring him to yourself
she's gonna die
oh maybe not
tala run taller run tolerant
you need to run
taller you need to ride
oh it's the droid
someone in the chat called it kenobi got
whooped which i knew he would if he
tried to fight this is the end of the
episode
okay
i mean
oh these got us you gotta step it up man
vader's hardcore
oh is it riva
oh hold up hold on
oh it's riva
yeah she dead run liar
oh no
oh no
yo
that was amazing
chris that was amazing
i don't hear chris anymore where'd he go
chris is gone
he was here now he's gone
now he's back
dude that was amazing
in a
long time
dude
that was pretty crazy cool
that was
wow
it feels star wars it it's
yeah
no i mean
wow
wow
yeah no this that was this was
fantasticals
classic heroes journey
overpowered villain and the comeback is
spectacular yes mr anderson
wow
yeah james earl jones came back as the
voice
gosh this is oh we can't hear chris hold
on
i mean we can hear chris now
hey that means
grass toucher what was the manda
reference
um
i'm wondering how much we'll see hayden
i mean we saw him a little bit
i think we'll see a couple more visions
of him but i don't think we'll see much
of actual hayden this is unfortunate
yeah but expected i suppose no of course
i mean he's not gonna not be in the
vader suit surely it keeps him alive
right surely at some point we see liam
i mean we've yeah i mean we've seen like
flashbacks already so yeah holy crap
odin lord raiden
uh chris would know that question was
tala the actress from game of thrones
the viper's wife
christopher oh you know what yeah i was
sitting here trying to figure out where
she was from i think you're right i
recognized her and i'm like i have no
clue what you're from
i knew it wasn't anything marvel i think
game of thrones is actually right yeah
rush kind one there you go i also have
decided
kenobi beat miss marvel in the poll 82
and after watching this episode yeah i
am doing watch parties for kenobi not
miss marvel we will pick up with mars
marvel after kenobi's over because holy
crap
i'm in this show
awesome i am in this show
and uh i am uh i am i'm here for it
uh sean bell
oh no i addressed that already uh wow
dude
okay
freaking vader
torturing him
the way he was
oh yeah torture even done with him he
walked away like yeah that's enough for
now
oh
he's not even like i couldn't get to him
he's like yeah well we talked about it
before we were like uh
i went live like an hour early um
we were talking about it before um
if they did fight in this episode vader
was gonna clap him like no doubt at all
but like vader
clapped
yo
vader
or i should say anakin
did not stop killing young lanes after
order 66 that dude snapped that kid's
neck
that was what i was about to say that's
that slow merciless walk up was pretty
crazy oh my gosh he was dragging people
and he killed that guy's dad and then he
killed the son and he left the mom and
oh my gosh yeah they was a kid that kid
was like 12 years old or something
uh trashbot yeah no i did see your super
chat i responded i guess you might have
jumped out let me go back to it
uh
you think we'll ever get darth maul
staying alone yeah yeah um
i think we actually do have like the
capacity to to get it now
actually uh
and i think with disney plus and
everything i think i think we could i
really do uh later on though not not
like
not within like the next two years
don't you think vader should have
used the force light to fire away yeah i
think vader's i think that's a part of
vader's just toying with him in all
honesty like holy crap like
obi-wan had no chance and it's like
the the the fear has just taken over
and or obi-wan like it's just all like
fear for him
you know he's terrified that's why all
of his decisions are based off of fear
he had
this has haunted him for 10 years
and now here it is and he didn't know
vader was alive and here he's and this
is like literally his worst nightmare
the person that
his padawan his brother the person that
he loved the monster he has become has
come back
and and and he's just he's paralyzed
like he didn't attack a single time he
just defended rather poorly but that's
what i expected
but
that was star wars and
i'm excited that was really cool
that was really really
cool
and i am uh
wow i'm really excited i was really
tired
oh i'm tired too but i mean worth
staying up and watching
it's uh
it's good to have those feelings of
excitement of star wars because
i've enjoyed mandalorian i've enjoyed a
lot of the disney plus series i'm not
going to act like i enjoyed this the
the
final trilogy we got i just didn't it
didn't give me the emotions that star
wars is famous for giving fans
um
but this was that you know this was me
being a kid watching revenge of the sith
not revenge of the sith um i mean yeah
yeah the third one for the third one
yeah yeah yeah okay i'm not wrong i am
very tired me sitting in the theater
watching revenge of the fifth the sith
and when i left my shirt was ripped in
the front because i had bit it to pieces
from anxiety nice and i've gotten those
feelings again watching just these
little scenes here and hopefully we'll
be getting much more and a little bit
more in depth and intense and in depth
as well with the dialogue yeah it's it's
insane
wow
um
yeah i agree mr anderson it was totally
expected uh
i don't think her writing's that
terrible to him i she definitely has a
riva sister three definitely has a story
behind
there's definitely a story behind why
she
doesn't like what she hates obi wan so
much
maybe she loves anakin right for like
the course of this 10 years because 10
years is you know happened in between um
i had a thought that maybe she's trying
to get to anakin to kill him too she
might just hate them all
maybe she's not in any future projects
so it's super feasible that she dies
right
yeah
kind of like a rogue one thing like you
realize these people all die because
right in future movies kind of like so
maybe she hates obi-wan because he kind
of abandoned her but he also hates
anakin for doing what he did and right
she's obviously aware of who he is and
everything and she's trying to get close
to him so she can take him out yeah
that was a thought yeah i actually like
that like
but i
i wonder i really wonder what her
because like she was clearly a jedi
turned seth right because that's what
happened so maybe she's faking it
maybe she's but also just it's pretty
classic this sith don't want to kill
your master no of course she wants to be
kind of she wants to and they're gonna
only be two
so
right so that's kind of the move is
let's kill our master i was just about
to say
who's the second one but obviously
sidious is in the background so yeah
i think we'll see at some point i think
we should
yeah i mean he's just such an integral
part to the entire skywalker saga yeah
and he's prominent character in the
original movies and this is between them
so yeah
grass toucher the man of reference was
that he said when you have your eyes
closed
you can see the way i don't remember
that from mandel
season one or season two
this is i mean it kind of is a thing the
whole way through i think season one
this is the way this is the way yeah i
mean i got that part i didn't know if
that was i love storm troopers
i don't know why because they're cool
i'm like high obsessed with them though
yeah the coolest minions in the history
of tv and there's like smarter now they
were so cool yeah dirt on their on their
their uniforms and like their operations
and stuff like you really see the
separation from when they were the
clones to when their stormtrooper
because they're different they're not
the same no right yeah
and yeah when we get the original empire
trilogy you don't really get to
appreciate the stormtroopers they very
are very much our side characters they
all sound the same they talk very
infrequently
but here where we get a little more of
this interaction with them and you see
that there are people and there's girls
there's guys there's it's super cool i
love that a lot personally as a fan of
stormtroopers
infamous offbeat yeah he is supposed to
be op vader is supposed to be a p that's
you know that's kind of vader's thing
he's a sith lord i mean
there aren't weak sith lords you know
no not really um
yeah the way no i get the way reference
yeah i totally get that yeah
um
yeah i mean it's like this is all
fear and you know we all know the famous
quote fear leads to which leads to
oh
there's very star wars guys
extremely
it's extremely
star wars
wow
i can't believe
first of all mustafar
like
awesome um
and dude he just messed up he literally
burned him
he like
and what's crazy
is that
obi-wan did nothing to anakin
he did nothing to anakin
and he's like you made me this and i
said i said while we were watching he's
like i am what you made me and i was
like you have done that
yourself he should he should have said
that he should have said that
but
wow that i love this hello freak
what frick bubba freak he goes he goes
hello
have said hello there
i know i know when he said that i was
like hello there just say it right say
it before the end of the series please
hello there it didn't have to be hello
there he he
he literally the first words of star
wars celebration
when it started owen and hayden walked
on stage it wouldn't hold the mic to his
mouth and he said hello there and
everyone went crazy the first words of
the entire star wars celebration
that's awesome so he's gotta say it in
the show
yeah the burning sequence is cool i'm
pumped we're obviously gonna get another
showdown between them
you can definitely tell
ben has a lot of feelings towards vader
and it's throwing him off and he hasn't
trained and we got a lot of stuff we got
lots to come well it's like
he's he already thought he killed him
so it's like
can he do it again
you know i am curious how much leia
learns
well she doesn't
really
exhibit any force sensitive powers and
the i mean she's got kind of this
discernment thing going on well but it
doesn't like
nothing really ever happens until
like we see that she trained as a jedi
with luke
and you know way later on way later but
uh during the original trilogy she
doesn't
no she doesn't exhibit any training or
anything but it's always stated that she
has force sensitivity
kind of i think it's not much i think i
i think that
if they even change luke if you won't do
it i'll just take your sister well
that's because
well yeah but that's just because he
knows right it's my daughter like
so i mean
no i mean really not i just watched them
all recently it's not really
she
it shows like that she's like connected
to him when he's like
[Music]
you know and vader just cut his arm off
and she's like turn around and that's
what's shown but she never says anything
about
being familiar with the force or
anything like that
and maybe since she doesn't ever really
say much you can kind of say that like
she knew all along but i tell you what i
bet you star wars star wars fans
are gonna be pissed if they like try to
retcon some stuff like you can't change
the original trilogies like
that's what's gonna piss people off
yeah that's where things start going
sideways but it doesn't even have to be
like training or force training i just
wonder if maybe she knows
a little bit like some of the details
behind the whole
but i don't know like you say they are
kind of in a box with what's already
been displayed
versus what they can change yeah
notorious media vader said f them kids
vader said order 66 ain't over and i'm
kim
i'm just killing all the kids now all
the young women were gonna get an angry
vader and we got an angry vader so
i did dude he snapped that kid's neck
that was intense
it was in a circus because it was
intense get it
yeah
louis very that's uh
you know
that that's a good point we're going to
get the final fire fight's going to be
amazing like
because this was amazing
this felt
so much like star wars oh that's really
like the only way to like properly
describe it though it does have the
feelings
when i was a kid you know what really
made me feel old
all the
we were having a chat about who's gen z
and who's millennial and stuff and all
these gen z's out there
yeah um going on like yeah i was
introduced to star wars with the clone
wars like yeah
like i watched crazy prequels and then
you've got some people in my chat even
like yeah i watched the actual release
on in the theaters of the first empire
church which is amazing i mean those are
the first movies i saw i saw all the
prequels in theaters
um
uh all of them yeah
yeah i know absolutely i was i was
introduced to star wars with the
prequels
uh i always loved them i never never i
never didn't like them oh i preferred
the prequels are kind of my favorite i'm
just you know that's why i was
interested i could get that could get me
canceled
but i i'm just no i stood up at star
wars celebration because
the like mc guy before
you know one of the panels started he
was like who loves
you know the original trilogy the most
who loves you know this the most this
most when he said prequels i stood up
and i was like i have no shame
yeah no it's true though like you gotta
own your introduction that's there's
literally people saying like oh yeah
i've been introduced to star wars with
the cartoons the clone wars and it's
like that's that's what was big when i
was i mean but that's just your age i
wasn't born in the 70s i'm sorry i
didn't watch the original thing it was
not my fault yeah i am who you made me
yeah
you saw the originals in theaters d
rabbit white dang look at you
well this is how's this for you must be
pretty cool i mean
dang compare it to those feelings um we
can't that's the thing yeah so tom does
disney ahsoka can fight vader
malachor basically go to toe toes okay
turn it to the mall and then yes obi-wan
did one shot maul seven years after a
lot can happen in seven years and i
think
after this series
uh he's gonna because he like put the
jedi like aside right and i think after
that no more of that like it's full
[Music]
back to the normal obi-wan back to
training again uh it's also seen that
all these jedi are out there and that
they're right and he he's not alone he
essentially let one die right in the
first episode of the second episode i
can't really remember and he needs to be
the change he wants to see right because
this is gonna happen
you know this show isn't gonna take
place over the course of years it's
the course of like a week right or
whatever it is so you know a lot can
happen in seven years
yeah
it could 100 lead to a
season two
so some people are asking about the fire
i get that vader probably could have
just used the force to let it out
but he might have an aversion to fire
guys remember his whole body was burned
out of his
his sick ways like i i think it's
torture i think it's totally kind of a
force link thing going on now yeah i was
able to find him and i think he's trying
to mess with i don't think he's worried
at all and i do too i think he's going i
think he wants him to suffer mentally
right because he he clearly
he clearly senses him and can sense how
he's feeling and everything and just by
fighting him you can look at him and go
wow like if i'm better i'm like wow i
screwed you up like me being back
yeah this is gonna be fun like you are
messed up dude like this is gonna be a
cakewalk and you know what i'm not
really worried about fighting you i'm
gonna torture you i'm gonna drag you
into some fire and you know what i'm
gonna let you live so
i could be in your brain more and then
i'll kill you eventually yeah yeah yeah
i i definitely got that vibe from it and
i could see people being like oh he just
couldn't get through the [ __ ] no
i don't that's what it is obviously the
stormtroopers running around like idiots
it's funny but
well that's just classic stormtrooper yo
that one storm trooper who fell over on
that gate sliced it out
i was a big fan of that i was like oh
that's awesome yeah
uh hunter you made a good point he said
this was just the beginning of ben's
pain he's torturing him and toying with
him yeah i 100 agree
he didn't he didn't plan to kill him
there
he wanted to torture no he told the
stormtroopers to go get him but he's
like yeah let him get away that's just
as bad because he's now going to be
looking over shoulder every every time
he turns around yeah he's going to be in
fear
yeah yeah andrew he lives in he vader
lives in ben's head rent free now he's
just
i mean he clearly let him go we we just
watched him over forced we watched him
lift him up in the air make him drop his
lightsaber drag him into fire like you
know vader let him go
now obi-wan is going to be having a
heart-to-heart with is good master liam
and then dude i cannot wait till we see
liam neeson because you know what has to
happen you can't i mean you can't just
say master quagga i master qui-gon and
then it's not and he's not in it like a
hundred percent there'll be something
for sure yeah
yeah
so
well dang
okay
that was uh
that was amazing getting better that was
that was three more that was star wars
we got three more
so guys i this poll is still up
uh you can vote in the poll but i think
next week instead of uh doing miss
marvel i'm gonna do obi-wan now i'm not
doing breakdowns for ob1
uh and i'm gonna do breakdowns for miss
marvel
so
give and take right
a lot of people are like oh can't you
just do both it really takes a lot out
of us you have no clue if we did both
i would die we won't do breakdowns at
least not until like yeah two days later
or something
because it's uh it's really after we hit
end stream we're up for another three
four hours well i explained before
stream like
with moon knight with loki one division
like we don't go to bed till like 8 a.m
it's it's hard to go get mcdonald's back
in the day and then
yeah right and then it screws up our
entire
sleep schedule for the week and by the
time it gets back to normal well it's
another episode watch party again
yeah
so i don't think just doing the watch
parties that's not as bad because now i
could just go to bed
yeah i mean maybe we could do it for me
yeah it's late for you early for you
so maybe we could do watch parties for
both and not do uh a breakdown right
away and we have seen the first two
episodes of miss marvel i've seen the
first episodes of miss marvel so you've
seen the first two yeah
yeah
yeah that may as well so that will help
at least with that for a little bit
yes lindsey schultz lindsay schultz i
knew a lindsay schultz in high school
did you go to colonial high school do i
know you
um
zach braff that's the voice i was
thinking of was it
fl flick
was that it was so familiar i couldn't
peg it yeah
interesting
uh yeah i might i'm i'm thinking i could
just do
miss marvel after
kenobi's finished because what it's
going to be the fourth episode which is
the fourth we're just getting one fifth
which is the second and then the sixth
which is the third so we'll pick up miss
marvel on the fourth episode without ob1
yeah i think that'll be fun
yeah i think that's fine we could do
that
vader's the most iconic villain in the
history of
cinema in my opinion they don't get much
bigger than vader
just
everybody recognizes what vader is even
people who don't know like brett
you know it's there's a lot of stuff
there you know it's darth vader uh there
are
six
miss marvel episodes and six miss marvel
episodes and they're kind of the same
length as obi-wan
between 35 and 50 minutes
yeah i'm wondering
did obi-wan use the lightsaber yes you
did ah
what was the queen and quinlan vos
reference
i haven't heard anything oh quinlan um
obi-wan trains him in clone wars no but
what was the reference
oh he had written a message inside the
tunnel oh yeah yeah yeah no no i did
catch that yeah now that i remember now
i remember that yeah because
quinlan
was here yeah yeah yeah yeah
i did yeah no um i thought tyler was
gonna die so i'm glad she didn't i
really yeah it's nice i really thought
tala was gonna die
yeah although teague does bring up a
good point
kind of mystical tunnel was that they
all went in the same direction and came
out in different ways dude i was so
confused about that i was like did she
go through the same part like she came
out a completely different place to
shoot a storm trooper she should have
just shot vader
that too i was like yeah
he would have stopped
uh
black tv black tv um
vader's mess with them
just messed him up he didn't mess with
that
yeah
yeah i'm confused about the tunnels
because i yeah i was confused when like
i was confused when she just showed up
on the other side when it she seemingly
went into the same way and then it's
like tala went out the tunnel and
i don't know yeah breva could have went
to the other side
and just
was like oh look here's a tunnel that
goes this way i'm just gonna go find the
other side
uh
and unlike the first episode i guess uh
little leia isn't faster than all the
adults anymore but we're not gonna talk
about that we don't talk about bruno
i could talk about that that was
ridiculous that was so bad
she was using the fourth woman no she
wasn't
he used a slowing charm yeah
uh charlotte they are bringing the
prequel lightsaber battles back that's
what they actually said we're going to
get more of uh
yo i'm getting some dungeons
sex spots go away
yeah those popped up a lot in uh
wendy and dustin's stream i don't know
you don't get them
i don't know if i do mr anderson took
care of him oh yeah my money hey here
so
mr real one though
i wonder if vader could bring it i mean
this sounds weird because vader
ultimately does kill obi-wan but i
wonder if right now vader could kill
obi-wan but he does seem really engulfed
in the hate
the darks you have to remember inside of
vader though is still a scared little
boy well that's what i'm saying so i
wonder if vader could even bring himself
to actually end
and ben's life he does eventually strike
me down
yeah but uh
it's uh
it's gonna be good we're gonna get a big
rematch and i'm curious to see if we get
like a little montage or meditation or
liam needs to show up or what that is
but
i uh i'm ready for
kenobi to
to tell
leia
that he knew her parents or at least
padme something like that now obviously
leia doesn't know
that vader is her father so i don't
think he you know he'd tell her i don't
think she'll figure that out because he
doesn't even look that
right
he doesn't even tell him that until
right he says vader killed
father which he technically did
trashbot star wars theory said vader was
too timid
well
i don't know i know he's got a huge star
wars channel but i uh i think i know
exactly what vader was doing and uh that
is toying with him not only physically
but mentally and emotionally as well
i don't think vader has any uh
like insecurity or
doubt in his mind that he could
absolutely crush obi-wan he could have
killed him there so easily right he
clearly didn't kill him there right
right so uh that's my i think that there
is
if if anything and we were just talking
about it there is kind of that little
scared boy inside of vader
that he wasn't ready to kill obi-wan yet
because he wants obi-wan to suffer right
it's not enough for vader to just kill
obi-wan no so he's playing with him he's
proving to himself
how easily he could kill and torture
obi-wan because he lost the first time
you know he's got to get all through all
vader is a complicated character he's
almost like a split personality vader
anakin inside outside that you see come
full circle so that's a big part of him
becoming lord vader is is defeating
anakin and he's proving to anakin look
how easy this is
fighting off anakin
i could have killed him you couldn't
know if that's why we're vader i'm
stronger right
but wait maybe that makes sense about it
the droid from rogue one would be gone
by now i don't
think so droid from road road would be
after
yeah one picked up exactly at episode
four this happens before
yeah this is before this is seven years
before
yeah
yeah cause rogue one ends exactly at the
beginning of four
yeah andor season two was announced at
star wars celebration i was there when
it was announced and that's going to
lead right up to rogue one which is cool
so we're going to have a great project
rogue one was fantastic holy crap by the
time
like two three is in the future there's
gonna be so much star wars you have to
watch from like start to finish holy
crap you're like new to the thing yeah
yeah
people will be like i got into star wars
on ob1 like oh
i've been corrected it's nine years
before
what oh
um
like i i do think palpatine's gonna be
in this at least in one episode i would
i would like to see at least a hologram
right even if it's in like the final
episode
we'll see
yeah but i think it was totally messing
with them like 100 he was just screwing
with him and he wants to torture him
some more this is revenge this isn't oh
yeah
this isn't oh let's kill him to get like
let's kill him to kill him this is not
that this is revenge there's something
in it for vader he says
he even says
i am what you made me in which i think
really obi-wan should have said you have
done that yourself i think that would
have been perfect
[Laughter]
but uh you're new and you're not against
me then you're my enemy
only a sith speaks an absolute i know
what i must do that said obi-wan in an
absolute sentence right
[Laughter]
it's best line we don't talk about it
this line best line best
uh i don't know if we're gonna see a
mace windu cameo that's really like i
feel like we keep expecting to see him
and he's just not gonna show up i don't
know if we'll ever see mason
star wars he is the mephisto of star
wars that's a great analogy i like that
uh what happened
something about star wars theory also i
don't know what that
same left star was there for this oh i
appreciate that i mean i used to talk to
some star wars fans like us
isn't his name paul
he revealed his name at one point i used
to talk to him before um
uh star wars theory uh but i mean yeah i
mean
opinions right we're all we can have our
opinions i personally think
uh vader was awesome and
i think that
i don't know i really really like this
and i uh i think vader was just messing
with them i mean it's
i think what was trying to be shown here
was
like
obi-wan kenobi is
haunted
by vader and then like he's he's been
haunted over the past 10 years could he
have saved his padawan his brother this
person that he loved was it his fault
what could he have done different to
make it to where he didn't turn to the
dark side like that's haunted him for so
long
and then he finds out he's still alive
and that's just like shatters his
everything right and then
all of a sudden he's there coming at him
with a lightsaber and just it's too much
and
that to me was what was supposed to be
shown here that and how much stronger
vader is because of the state of mind
kenobi is in plus
he hasn't been a jedi for 10 years
and
also truth be told vader probably is
stronger than ben oh of course yeah i
think so
like
obi-wan was at the peak at the end of
the third movie and anakin was still
trying to figure himself out but vader
is
in my mind undoubtedly stronger
right
t rob brown that's funny that name has
no meaning for me now nor to the lives
of young ladies i can't believe he
stacked that snap that dude's neck so
and that's that's the point they're
trying to show how ruthless vader is and
he doesn't care about anything but
torturing opioid
now that's gonna be his full focus at
the moment so
uh
that's an interesting thought
michael fox blood do you think obi-wan's
baby brother might have been anakin or
is that a stretch i don't know the
i don't know the age difference
because
obi-wan would have been taken
from look guys i i'm the first to admit
all of the lore books and stuff like
that i haven't read i'm a fan of the
star wars movies and shows um movies and
shows came out first right do i know a
lot about the movies and says yes am i
like am i do i know star wars like a new
marvel no do i know star wars like an
odc no i just love star wars uh i will
do my best to learn more um and i should
read some books but that's why i'm not
like doing breakdowns of ob1 because i
don't think that's right now
uh
halibur video
i don't think i would offer a lot i
think i would offer some good stuff
but i would like to do more theories and
stuff about it um and hopefully one day
we'll get to the point where you know
i'm doing some breakdowns that we want
i'm a fan that's what i'm doing here
right i'm a i'm a big fan going back to
you're pretty crazy yeah this is like i
think star wars got me started i
remember sitting in my home in pensacola
florida the city i was born and uh i
remember we had a florida room which is
like outside but it has a screen in it
and a roof and i would play with like my
death star and you know my x wings and i
played the star trek stuff too because
my dad loved star trek and made me watch
star trek and cup and that's like that
got me into it like when i was like five
years old and that's where i am now
like i'm just loving it
so
hey thanks cnb i appreciate that
yeah
so
uh
i mean i'm pretty satisfied as a star
wars fan
mm-hmm mean
i mean yeah so but uh
having to send an opinion but don't just
show up here to say that this sucks uh
yeah i mean
i try not to be like a lot of people
always say like oh you don't ever
dislike anything that's not true
it's just really hard for me to hate
something
it's really hard for me to say something
sucks i'm sure a lot of people are gonna
say miss marvel sucks i don't think it
sucks it's just not for me
but i can sit back and say like
as a show it doesn't suck
it's just different
and a lot of people are gonna really
love it and a lot of people are gonna
hate it i already know that i don't know
i don't think there's much that could
reasonably be i think there can always
be a reasonable argument and i don't
think there's enough here to reasonably
argue
like this is bad because like yeah okay
the little running scene with the little
girl was weird it's like okay get over
it like
you're not picking
i am a tricky hard chest totally
big tricky i have lots of signed tricky
stuff
[Laughter]
oh danny that's good to hear die hard
star wars fan
loved this episode that that's awesome
that's that's awesome uh why didn't
vader just put the fire out i just think
he's letting him get away to torture his
mind
i'm coming for you obi-wan like
i also have a psychology degree
so i that's that's the that's the thing
in me so uh all right guys so we're
gonna get off because it's late and i'm
tired and uh we are from now on
uh we're not doing a miss marvel watch
party next week we're gonna keep with
kenobi till it finishes and then we'll
pick up miss marvel there uh thanks
disney for dropping them with the
freaking sims you're not gonna do miss
marvel after then we might we might do
miss marvel after
that might make my life a lot easier
actually
so
we're going to do both we'll do obi-wan
and then miss marvel but don't expect to
break down hours later
i'm going to sleep back i'm going to be
sleeping right exactly
exactly exactly so all right
i love everybody i love this episode of
star wars i i
i
i loved it i thought it was awesome i i
really do i hope it gets i hope it stays
the same or gets better so
uh thank you to mr anderson
awesome mod uh hunter was in here thank
you he's probably gone now um
uh william robertson massive star wars
fan of this episode
uh this episode was everything i wanted
in star wars so happy awesome awesome
man uh yeah hey some people are gonna
like miss marvel d rabbit white and
that's cool uh like i said i'm enjoying
the ride uh i did not think it sucked by
any means i just think it's catered to a
younger audience but i think a lot of
older audiences are gonna like it as
well i'm i'm open-minded and i hope it
gets i hope it stays good and everything
so this uh
i think it i think i think it's this
show's gonna be
is gonna be it so
uh
we'll see you next week um
check out chris's channel cosmoculture
uh mr anderson post stuff on his channel
too and he's gonna get back in that so
uh
yeah
be sure to check those guys out um
yep
hayden and james killed this yep
yep it was really cool so
all right everybody i'll see you next
week and look out for my videos coming
tomorrow
love you all 2 000. no way i want to
change it i don't want to say i love you
all 3000 anymore i want to say i love
you all in every universe
because i really like that quote from dr
strange i was pretty freaking it was
pretty freaking awesome so all right